-Last time you were here,
it was very interesting,
I think, for me.
We were all trying to figure out
how to pronounce your name.
-Yeah.
-And now here you are --
You're a major contender
for getting
the Democratic nomination.
You just got a big day today.
The polls came out,
and you're number three
in the polls in Iowa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What do you attribute
your surge in popularity to?
-Well, hard work, a really good
team, and the right message.
I think our message
is what Americans
are really looking for.
It's not just how to end
the Trump presidency,
which is obviously
a huge priority,
because our country's future
depends on it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But it's also about
what's America going to need the
day after this presidency ends?
This presidency will come
to an end one way or the other.
And when we get there, when the
sun comes up over this country,
and we're picking up the pieces
and figuring out what's next,
I think it's going to require
that we're ready to undertake
bold solutions, but also that
we can bring people together.
And that's been the core
of our campaign.
And I think it's resonated.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think, the last debate,
I think you scored major points
for a lot of people during that
because, one, with Elizabeth
Warren, you challenged her
and actually debated, as you
would in a debate, with her
about her Medicare for All.
-Yeah.
-And you were saying,
"How do you pay for all this?"
And she didn't really
have an answer.
-It's a respectful, honest,
but major difference of opinion.
First of all, when you're
proposing something like this,
it's got to be clear
how it's paid for.
And the plan
that I'm putting forward,
we call it "Medicare
for all who want it,"
can be paid for without raising
middle-class taxes.
And it's got a lot
of other advantages, too,
because it lets people keep
their private plans.
So the basic idea is
we take a version of Medicare.
We make it available
for anybody who wants it,
but if for some reason
you prefer a different plan,
that's okay. I'm not going
to make you switch.
And I just think
that's better than saying,
"You've got to do Medicare
whether you want to or not,"
and make that entire change
for the entire country
in four years or less.
So it's just an honest
difference of opinion.
-And I saw a lot of people
were saying, like,
"Oh, well, wait a second,
Mayor Pete.
You said that -- You tweeted out
that you were
for Medicare for All..."
-Yeah.
-"...a couple years ago."
So what do you say to that?
-Yeah, for the long run,
that's still my preference.
I just think we got to have
some humility about this.
In other words,
to get from here to there,
it makes more sense
to make it optional.
And then if we're right, that
that's going to be the best plan
for all Americans, then
all Americans will choose it,
and it'll become the only plan.
And if we're wrong,
and some Americans would rather
be on something different,
well, then we're going
to be really glad
we didn't kick them
off the plans they had
and force them onto ours.
So it's a similar vision
about where I think
the destination's going to be,
but an approach
that is more practical
and I think more flexible
for Americans
who I trust to make
the right decision
on what's right for them.
-I think another thing
that where you scored --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Another area where you scored
in the debate
is when -- with Beto O'Rourke,
and you kind of, you guys
kind of sparred a little bit
about gun reform.
And would you like to talk
about your stance on that and --
-Well, first of all, I think we
all want to get real gun reform.
There's been way too much talk
for way too long.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I think the focus right now
is we've got to have
universal background checks.
By the way,
Republicans agree on this --
not so much Republican
members of Congress,
but the Republicans
across America,
and Washington still hasn't
been able to get it done.
We got to go further than that.
We got to have red flag laws
that disarm domestic abusers.
And we've got to ban the sale
of these assault weapons
and the high-capacity magazines
to load them.
That will save lives in America.
And we've got to do it
right away.
-And that's a --
It's a big issue for you.
If you do become President,
you'll -- you'll --
that'll be one of your focuses?
-Yeah, I mean,
we can't go on like this.
You know, I was in high school
when the Columbine
shooting happened.
And since then, we've generated
a second
school-shooting generation.
Shame on us if we allow there
to be a third.
[ Applause ]
-And you know these guns
because you've seen
these assault rifles.
You were in Afghanistan.
-Yeah.
-What is your take on everything
with Syria and Turkey and --
-I got to tell you,
it's just a bad day for America
when our country can't be
relied on to keep its word.
You know, I really felt
when I was deployed
that, in addition
to my body armor
and the weapons I was carrying,
that one of the things
that protected me
was that the flag on my shoulder
represented a country
that was seen as credible,
that our allies
and our enemies knew
that when we said we would do
something, we would do it.
So when you got
these Kurdish fighters,
they put their lives on the line
to be at our side
fighting against ISIS,
and you betray them,
which is what
this president has done,
not only is it undermining
stability in Syria,
it's undermining
the honor of American soldiers
who feel now that their honor
has been taken away.
And when you take away
a soldier's honor,
you're taking away
the most important thing.
And it's taking away
our country's honor.
It makes the world
a more dangerous place.
And when I am president,
when I am Commander in Chief,
we will restore
American credibility,
because lives depend on it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know you're in New York,
and I saw that you were riding
the subway today, which is --
There you are right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know if you were here --
I don't know if you were here
to stop by "Saturday Night Live"
to ask them to stop doing
an impression of you.
I don't know.
But I don't if you saw,
they did an impression of you.
But they're not on this week.
But yeah, you didn't see it?
-I didn't see it.
[ Laughter ]
-You didn't see it at all?
-No.
-No, you didn't see it.
-Was it good?
-Well, we have --
Here's a here's a clip
of Colin Jost playing Mayor Pete
on "Saturday Night Live."
Take a look.
-Hi.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much. Thank you.
I went to Harvard,
but they don't teach you
where to put your arms.
Why am I not winning this,
you know?
I'm a veteran.
I'm under
the legal retirement age.
And when I talk, it makes sense.
Is something wrong with me?
-No, no, you're a great guy,
just, like, as a friend,
not for president.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, you like it?
-It's okay.
-It's okay. It's not --
It wasn't that bad.
-Yeah, I just want to say I'm
very comfortable in my own body.
I know exactly what to do
with my arms.
I don't know --
-But now you're over-thinking
what to do with your arms now?
-Yeah, now, I'm wondering.
Are they too far out,
too far in?
-I'll make it easy for you.
I just want to shake your hand.
Thank you for coming
on our show tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mayor Pete Buttigieg, everybody!